ich starte die aufnahme meiner minecraft
videos immer schon bevor ich meine welt
betrete so dass falls direkt irgendwas
krasses passieren sollte ich es auch auf
kamera habe und genau so einen moment
gab es heute leider
[Musik]
ich habe die aufnahme nicht mehr
gestartet
ja ich habe die aufnahme gestartet aber
ich konnte ich kann ich mit sprachen
lernen da ich bin nicht mal einer
verdammten begrüßung gekommen und schon
fällt ist ein snickers hallo und
herzlich willkommen hier heute meine
lieben freunde zu einer neuen episode
von minecraft mit luca ich freue mich
euch wer dich kapitän voll neben der
spur direkt brief an meine fresse ich
darf euch heute recht herzlich zu einer
neuen episode von minecraft mit luca
willkommen als meine lieben freunde ich
freue mich wirklich sehr euch mitteilen
zu dürfen dass ich die komplette farm
abreißen werde
ja wir haben zwar extrem viele von euch
geschrieben hey luca das mit dem
trichter jungen liegt daran dass ich den
trichter auf die kiste hätte platzieren
sollen die sache ist allerdings und das
ist irgendwie jetzt aufgefallen und zwar
muss ich ganz ehrlich sein ich habe
keine richtige lust auf sonne krasse
form hier unter wasser weil und das ist
der sinn in meinen augen von diesem
projekt und deswegen habe ich auch
angefangen ich habe einfach mehr bock
auf so was süßes entspanntes und
brauchen jetzt nicht unbedingt hier so
ein riesiges unterwasser dingen wo dann
irgendwie weiß ich nicht total viel
eisen kommt uns weiter und so fort von
daher habe ich mich ein bisschen schlau
gemacht und möchte in dieser folge eine
halbautomatische unter wasser über
wasser ich will auf jeden fall eine
halbautomatik das ist doch nicht deren
ernst
[Musik]
ich verstecke mich hinter ein baum der
kommt trotzdem nach rom oder wie stirb
so wollen nämlich alle verarschen
[Musik]
zwei stunden später
danke für die hilfe mit dem trichter das
hat mich wirklich extrem viele leute
geschrieben
die sache ist allerdings das hab ich ja
gerade schon gesagt ich möchte er eine
farm über wasser bauen also über land wo
ich halt wirklich stolz drauf bin
die auch schön aussieht und so weiter
und so fort die mit ihren bauen und dann
mache ich das jetzt erst mal ein
bisschen frei so ich damit noch mal eben
schnell hier die setzlinge ein die
können wir für später gebrauchen ich
möchte auch noch so eine kleine feier
ecke machen mit bäumen und so weiter und
so fort
und bevor die sonne untergeht kann ich
jetzt auch endlich mal die blumen hier
neben die margeriten das hat nämlich
auch einige geht in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich doch jetzt endlich
mal die blumen hier hinsetzen soll ich
mach das einfach so ein bisschen so weiß
nicht ob ihr die fahrt auf der anderen
insel dahinten ich habe wirklich richtig
kann es eigentlich keine erzählen ich
habe eine stunde alleine einfach heute
morgen minecraft gespielt und mir
überlegt wie ich eine schöne farbe bauen
kann kommen und ich habe mir vielleicht
auch ein youtube video dazu angeguckt
zunächst aber brauchen wir eine
bruchstein farm zack zack
und jetzt kann man nämlich hier einfach
das wasser einfüllen hier die lava und
hat jetzt selbst und bei euch so ich
werde jetzt allerdings auf jeden fall
erstmal die ganzen materialien formen
gehen und dann sehen wir uns gleich
sofort wieder
[Musik]
fertig oh mein gott das waren jetzt
sechs minuten alter das war ziemlich der
gerichte minecraft speed renner werden
alter wer streams 234 dann hier das tor
hindern wieder 1234
ich fange gerade erst an irgendeiner
folge müssen wir wirklich mal die
komplette insel reparieren gut weiter
mit unserer farm wir müssen auf jeden
fall hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
und hier auch nochmal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 jetzt passt das ja auch perfekt
mit dem grab von der cusack hier nochmal
du drauf und jetzt hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
das ist die größe unseres feldes jetzt
nehmen wir unsere stein ziegelmauern die
zäune und die eichen holztreppen plus
die eichenholz stufen und bauen jetzt
hier so zack zack zack dann hier das
nochmal darauf so und wie komme ich will
schon wieder bei 40 minuten in minecraft
folgende vergehen wirklich so
geisteskrank wie im flug es ist so
heftig ich merke aber auch einfach dass
wir dieses projekt so unfassbar viel
spaß macht und gerade das zeigt es ja
auch dass die folgen in meiner ansicht
nach so schnell vorbei gehen wissen wie
ich meine
mir macht das einfach extrem viel spaß
alles und ich weiss ich sag das total
häufig allerdings glaube ich dass es
euch auch spaß macht und dass da einer
mit irgendwas ich glaube ich sollte
ich glaube dieses projekt tut mir gerade
aktuell extrem gut ich habe darüber ja
schon in folge ja so soll die farben
später auf jeden fall nicht aussehen ich
habe darüber bereits vor einigen folgen
geredet und zwar befand ich mich lange
zeit wirklich in der war warum bist du
in meiner farm zu den cocos ordnung sie
ist ja nicht mal irgendwas besser so
nein wirklich dann auch abbauen
jetzt kommen auf jeden fall auch noch
zwei laternen hin
dann werde ich jetzt mal die falltüren
nehmen die platzieren wir nämlich einmal
hier so und dann nochmal hier so von der
anderen seite denn nun können wir die
wassereimer nehmen und nämlich genau
hier und hier wasser hin setzen dass wir
gleich alles mit redstone verkabelt dann
kriege ich jetzt einen kleinen knopf in
dann kann ich das quasi auf machen es
wird wundervoll freue mich und ich fühle
mich gerade wie 13 die einen
schleifstein noch eine kette und hier
unten ins wasser auch dann sieht auch
ein bisschen mehr aus wie ein brunnen
siege was sie jetzt machen muss die
redstone verkabelung das ist tatsächlich
leider auch das schwierigste
ja drückt mir die daumen dass es jetzt
geklappt ich brauch erde und muss glaube
ich hier eine redstone fackel hinsetzen
hier ein repeater hier wieder erde
redstone packe ich bin mir wirklich
nicht sicher war mit retter noch nie gut
für mich ist so ein bisschen wie physik
damals in der schule das ist das ist
nicht so mein ding ja aber du warst ja
nicht mehr in der schule auf jeden fall
können wir jetzt hier ein blog umsetzen
glaube ich und dann hier auch alles
zubauen glaube ich ich sagen wie viel zu
oft glaube ich ja moment der wahrheit
meine lieben freunde habe ich direkt an
verkabelung richtig gemacht dann wird
das wasser hier gleich raus treten kurz
und dann direkt wieder da reinkommen
also wir sind gespannt ich drücke den
knöpfen 32
ich dulde habt die blöcke und nicht die
falten verkabelt eben musik meine lieben
freunde trommelwirbel bitte einsetzen
wird es mit der automatischen parat
jetzt funktioniert ich bin jetzt nicht
so megastolz auf mich aber eigentlich
schon also es ist jetzt natürlich nicht
so als wenn ich jetzt die den
kohlenstoff erfunden hätte oder so bist
du schon mal ein heilmittel für
unheilbare krankheit nicht ich mache
meine hacke kaputt die sache ist werden
es natürlich nicht direkt daneben wasser
dann wird das nämlich alles noch mal ein
bisschen schneller wachsen
allerdings sind wir hier direkt am
tageslicht und es funktioniert besser
finde ich als eben wieder unten wenn wir
immer so eine leiter nehmen müssen um
dann nach unter zu gehen sieht schöner
aus wir haben es hier mitten auf unserer
web wir können das mit dem weg ganz
schön verbinden das muss ich gleich noch
so ein bisschen machen allerdings glaube
ich dass mir jeder von euch in den
kommentaren und beziehungsweise mir
jeder von euch in den kommentaren
zustimmen kann dass das hier deutlich
schöner und ästhetischer ist als in
seinem weg die wir dann hier runter
gehen und so weiter und so fort
von daher werde ich jetzt mal eine
schaufel nehmen hier den weg so ein
bisschen ausbessern zack da läuft dann
hier so lang so da irgendwie so ein
bisschen drin
ich bin umgeben von nichts können ich
werde jetzt auf jeden fall noch einige
setzlinge hier platzieren damit wir in
der nächsten folge vielleicht sogar
schon so ein bisschen mehr holz hier
wieder haben und damit auch alles
ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen schöner
aussieht hier unsere insel es leider
wirklich durch die krise extrem zerstört
worden und ich bin
nicht sehr stark dafür dass wir
irgendwann im nächsten komplette xxl
folge machen vielleicht auch uncut das
hat man sich viele gewünscht in der wir
ja alles so ein bisschen ausbessern
was ich auch mal machen könnte wäre das
knochenmehl nehmen und das hier so ein
bisschen verteilen haben wir auch viele
geschrieben
dadurch kriegen nämlich einerseits ein
paar mehr blumen die wir dann für die
deko vielleicht von einem traumhaus
hände benutzen können was ich ja dann
dem genau übermorgen ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt verteile ich hier noch ein
bisschen knochenmehl es wird jetzt
allerdings schon dunkel von daher gehe
ich noch mal ganz kurz kennen und dann
schauen wir uns das gleich mal an wie es
hier jetzt mittlerweile aussieht ich
finde wirklich mittlerweile bin ich
extrem happy mit dem erbe schaut euch
das mal an
wir haben diese farm heute gebaut es
sieht alles deutlich grüner aus wenn die
bäume jetzt gewachsen und guckt euch mal
einen hier zur demonstration sagt guck
mal wie schön dass sie dann aussieht das
ist ja voll
dann wird hier noch mal ein schönes
neues haus stehen das kommt dann in der
nächsten folge wahnsinn da hinten haben
wir auch noch die kommission film
geschafft heute also es war wirklich es
war eine produktive folge ich bin stolz
auf uns ich bin stolz auf uns stolz das
kann einen daumen hoch unter media
abonniert nur ein kanal wenn ihr keine
videos mehr verpassen wollt es ist
kostenlos und super das auch super ist
es dass hier bei merchandise es gibt es
zu kaufen geben
[Musik]